à montmartre c'est une tradition depuis
comme chaque année en septembre on
vendange c'est la plus grande vigne de
paris avec ses mille sept cent soixante
deux pieds de pinot noir et de gamme et
n'en déplaise aux grands vignobles
français
les gestes sont les mêmes mais lépinay
qui on coupe la grappe ci-après entrin
les mauvais démons et puis on garde les
moins qu'ils étaient mauvais et
heureusement des débats ce groupe qui
sont en scène donc devant les laiteries
il n'y aura pas de problème
hésitation je pense pas entretenue par
la mairie du 18e ce sont sans doute les
seuls vignes exposées au nord qui
devrait pourtant donné 400 litres devant
le clos montmartre un petit cru local
qui se bonifient paraît-il d'année en
année c'est un vin qui est vain culturel
on pourrait dire mais en fait il manque
un petit peu de corps mais on a quand
même des caractéristiques de montmartre
habituel c'est-à-dire pas mal d'esprits
beaucoup de fruits thé des arômes de
muer en de fruits de la forêt de fruits
noirs plutôt vendu 54 euros la bouteille
au profit des oeuvres sociales du xviiie
arrondissement
ce vin sera célébrée le 5 octobre
prochain pour la fête des vendanges
parrainé cette année par maxime le
forestier le disait le carnet sur les
vins de touraine du vin qu'on peut voir
quand on a soif